[موسيقى]
نحييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء
الاخضر يهزم التانجو في مباراه تاريخيه في
افتتاح المجموعه الثالثه
بهدفين مقابل واحد
[موسيقى]
بسببي عمليات الامتحان تويتر تؤجل مجددا
اطلاقا خدمه توثيق الحسابات بالعلامات
الزرقاء
الولايات المتحده وروسيا دونان القصف
التركي شمال سوريا والعراق وتطالبان انقره
بضبط نفس
صواريخ وبريطانيه موجهه بالليزر تصل كاف
وتوقعاته بان ترجيح كفه المعارك لصالح
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
سجلت السعوديه اليوم واحده من مفاجات كاس
العالم لكره القدم 20 22 بفوزها على
الارجنتين بقياده ليونيل ميسي بنتيجه 2-1
ميسي الذي يسعى للفوز باللقب الكبير
الوحيد الذي يتمناه قبل انهاء مسيرته
الكرويه صدم ببدايه ناريه من المنتخب
السعودي ما اعاد ذكريات فوز الكاميرون
واحد صفر على الارجنتين بقياده دييغو
مارادونا في المباراه الافتتاحيه لكاس
العالم عام 1990
هدفها صالح الشهري وسالم الدوسري في خمس
دقائق في الشوط الثاني منح الفوز
للسعوديين وتقدمت الارجنتين مبكرا بضربه
جزاء في الدقيقه
دربنا اخضر
قلبنا اخضر
فلنه اخضر كلنا الاخضر
دربنا اخضر قلب
نا اخضر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بلا اخضر اخضر
مها فرح العالمين
[موسيقى]
مع منافسات كاس العالم الاخرى مثل فوز
السنغال 1 0 على فرنسا حاملات اللقب في
افتتاح مونديال عام 2002 والولايات
المتحده على انجلترا بنفس النتيجه عام
1950 السعوديه اذن اليوم انهت سلسله الله
هزيمه للمنتخب الارجنتيني بعد الست
وثلاثين مباراه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ايوه ايوه ايوه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قال الى الماسك مالك منصه تويتر انها شركه
التواصل الاجتماعي قررت تاجيل اطلاق خدمه
الاشتراك بالعلامات الزرقاء وهو تاخير عن
الجدول الزمني المبدئي لاعاده الخدمه على
المنصه وارجع ماسك في تغريده على تويتر
سبب تاجيل اعاده اطلاق علامه التحقق
الزرقاء الى ضروره التحقق والحصول على ثقه
عاليه في حال انتحال الهويه مضيفا انه قد
يعرض استخدام لون مختلف لمؤسسات عن
الافراد تم الطرح اختيار الاشتراك المفتوح
لاي شخص على استعداد للدفع في وقت سابق من
هذا الشهر لمساعده تويتر على زياده
الايرادات بينما عاده واوقف الخدمه بعد ما
انتشرت الحسابات المزيفه وقال حينما ان
الخدمه ستتم اعاده اطلاقها في التاسع
والعشرين من نوفمبر وفي ملف تويتر ايضا
اطلقت شركات منافسه شرعا ان كنت لا تحب
ماسك تعالى وعمل معنا الاستقطاب الموظفين
السابقين تويتر من ذوي الكفاءات
والاستفاده من خبراتهم وتجاربهم
[موسيقى]
التنفيذيين وخفض اعداد الموظفين دون سابق
انذار اثريستيلائه على منصه تويتر تحت
شعار اذا كنت لا تحب ماسك تعالى واعمل
معنا شركه التقنيه تستقطب موظف تويتر
الذين غدروا الموقع رساله الى كل من ترك
التويتر نشرتها احدى الشركات تطالبهم
بالالتحاق بها ورغم ان شركه التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه الكبرى الاخرى بما في ذلك متى
وامازون قامت بتسريح الاف الموظفين في
الاسابيع الاخيره بسبب البيئه الاقتصاديه
لكن الانتقاد العالميه لماسك يصلط الضوء
على الطلب القوي على العمال الرقمين ذوي
المهارات الاليه الذين شغلوا مناصب حساسه
في تويتر ولعل شركات التكنولوجيا
الامريكيه المنافسه تسعى للاستفاده من
خبره هؤلاء الموظفين والمهندسين خاصه بعد
نجاحات السنوات الماضيه التي حققها طائره
تويتر برفقتهم
ما في غضون ذلك تخبطات المنصه مستمره في
ظل قرارات المالك الجديده ايلون ماسك الذي
جعل العالم كله يهتم باخبر تويتر اكثر من
اي شيء اخر بلال العربيه
حسين الطود اهلا بك حسين يعني انت انت منذ
اربعه ايام تقريبا متواجد امام مبنى تويتر
لاستطلاع اي جديد قبل ان اسالك عن موجه
الاقالات الجديده هل من معلومات حول اسباب
اامم تاجيل التوفيق العلامات الزرقاء
تحيه لك راويه من الواضح كما يقول خبراء
بان الوم ماسك الان وتويتر لديه نقص
بالمهندسين ولهذا السبب اا هو ما فتح باب
التوظيف من جديد كما قيل يريد عدد من
الموظفين لكي يساعدوه على اجراء كل
السياسات او كل ما يريد فعله بالنسبه
للعلامه الزرقاء هذا التاخير باطلاقها
يعود الى النقص في
المهندسين الذين استقال عدد كبير منهم ايه
نحن نتحدث عن الف ومئتين موظف جزء كبير
منهم كان تقني من التقنيين ومن المهندسين
لعل هذا هو السبب الرئيسي لتاخير الام
ماسك اعلان همم
بالنسبه للعلامه الزرقاء همم الحساب حسين
يعني كان هناك حديث امس عن موجه جديده من
همم طرد لموظفين او اقصاء لموظفين تويتر
فعليا هل هناك من معلومات ان كان هذا
المسلسل سيستمر بالايام
راويه البارحه كانت اخر وجبه
بالاقالات وكانت في قسم المبيعات همم صحف
امريكيه نقلت عن مصر قوله
للموظفين الذين عقد معهم اجتماع هنا في
هذا المركز الرئيسي لتويتر بان مرحله
الاقالات قد انتهت البارحه والان هناك همم
مرحله التوظيف يريد عدد من الموظفين لا
سيما في قسمين الهندسه وقسم المبيعات ولل
بالمناسبه البارحه نلتقيت بشخص هنا كان يا
خارجا من همم مركز من الشركه شركه تويتر
سالته هل هو موظف اجاب الى ان اتيت لكي
ابحث عن وظيفه
واخبرني بانه عندما وصل الى بوابه تويتر
بوابه الشركه واخبر همم
عمليه الاستقبال هناك بانه يريد وظيفه
استقباله خير استقباله سمحوا له بالصعود
الى الشركه يقدم سيرته الذاتيه قال لي
انهم عملوني كبير وارحب يبدو ان ايلهم
ماسك الان بدا يبحث عن عدد كبير من ال-
المهندسين رغم ان الموقع حتى الان لم
يشير لانه يريد موظفين ولكن بحسب نقله
الصحف الامريكيه عنه خلال الاجتماع انه
يشجع موظفي تويتر الان على تزكيه الاشخاص
الذين يرون انهم جيدون للعمل معه هو يريد
ان يبني خاصه همم قسم الهندسه من جديد من
الصفر وهو اخبر الموظفين البارحه ايضا
دائما حسب وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه بان
المرحله الهيكل او اعاده الهيكل الشركه هي
تمر باخطاء ولكن على المدى البعيد هي
ستكون ثابته وهو يريد ان يقدم او يذهب
الان الى تويتر اثنان ولهذا السبب يريد
نظام جديد وبحاجه الى مهندسين جدد من هذا
المنطلق هو همم يبحث عن مهندسين يعلن عن
ذلك قريبا بشكل رسمي كما علمنا من وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه
وانت تتحدث يعني اود ان اطلب منك يعني ان
كان بالامكان تحريك الكاميرا همم بالقرب
من مبنى تويتر لنرصده الحركه همم واود ان
نسلك هنا عن ما تم الحديث عنه عن اعطال
بالموقع ما حيثيات او ا ا ا ا المعلومات
التي تبينتها حول هذا الموضوع
همم
حسب وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه نقلت عن
خبراء وعن مستخدمين لتويتر انه خلال نهايه
الاسبوع كان هناك عطل في نظام همم حمايه
حقوق النشر التلقائي همم فهو قد توقف بشكل
كامل ما سمح لعدد من المستخدمين مستخدمين
تويتر يعني يرفع افلاما باكملها همم على
المنصه هذا امر هو غير مسموح به بحسب حقوق
النشر ولكنهم قاموا بتقسيم هذه الافلام
على مده دقيقتين دقيقتين لان نظام التويتر
لا يسمح بنشر اكثر من دقيقتين من الافلام
بحسب الخبراء هذا يشير الى هشاشه وضعف
وعدم استقرار نظام التويتر الان بسبب ان
نقص في التقنيين الذين عاده كانوا يقومون
بصيانته وبالبحث عن اخطاء لحلها الان هناك
نقص كبير وهذا ما يدل على مطالبه الى
الناس يكون
بان يساعدوه على احضار مهندسين وهو ايضا
بنفسه كما طلب سابقا من مهندسين في تسلا
بان ياتوا الى هنا الى هذا المقر الذي يقف
امامه بالمناسبه همم هناك هي بوابه تويتر
وهنا وهنا امام هذه البوابه التقيد
بالشابه الذي اخبرتك عنه وطلب همم موظفيه
او من مهندسين تسلم ويساعده الموظفين في
تويتر على صيانه همم الموقع من همم من
الهجمات وعلى ان يحلوا اي مشكله قد
يواجهها همم الكثيرون يقولون بان تويتر لن
ينقطع بشكل مفاجئ وبشكل كامل ولكن سيواجه
مشاكل وهذه المشكله همم
نظام حمايه حقوق النشره التلقائي تدل على
تدل على ذلك واحده من المشاكل التي وجهها
اضافه مثلا الى موضوع همم الموقع خاصه
فيما يخص همم طيب
شكرا لك
العربيه من امام مبنى توتير في سان
فرانسيسكو
يشعر مستخدم وتر في بريطانيا بالقلق من
تزايد الاخبار الزائفه على المنصه فضلا عن
الخطاب العنصري كما يحذر خبراء من ان
ايجاد بدء التويتر على المدى القصير قد لا
يكون امره سهله
خشيه كبيره يشعر بها مستخدم تويتر في
بريطانيا بعد الاضطرابات التي شهدتها
المنصه الاجتماعيه اثر استحواذ ال الماسك
عليها فما لبس ان استلم مسك شؤون شركه حتى
بدا بتغييرات جذريه لاسباب الاقتصاديه
واخرى سياسيه وصفها البعض بانها تخينه
في ما وصف خبراء وماسك بانه لا يعرف ماذا
يقوم به وقد برزت الى الواجهه منصه مثل
هايف وغيرها كخيار من دون ان تثبت كفاءتها
حتى الساعه في الحلول محلات تويتر
لن يقرر العالم كله مره واحده الانتقال
الى منصه جديده ولهذا السبب اعتقد انه من
الصعب استبداله بسهوله اعتقد فعليا ان
تويتر هو الخيار الوحيد الذي لدينا
والى جانب التغريدات المثيره للجدل التي
ينشرها ماسك بين الحين والاخر وتسريح
عشرات الموظفين من مكاتب الشركه حول
العالم او موجه الاغلاقات التي طالت
مكاتبهم بشكل مؤقت او دائم احيانا وفرض
رسوم على مستخدمي الاشاره الزرقاء وقراري
ماسك باعاده الشخصيات المثيره للجدل مثل
ترامب وكانيوست كل هذه الاسباب ربما تكون
دفعت العديده الى البحث عن منصه تواصل
بديله او الى تقليص الوقت الذي يقدمه على
المنصه همم
الكثير من الاخبار الزائفه مثل التعليقات
المعاديه للساميه او العنصريه التي سيتاح
للناس الان التحدث بها
رئيس تويتر على ماسك الاهتمام بموظفه هو
لا يقوم بذلك الان بعد تسريح العديد كما
ان اتاحه الفرصه لدونالد ترامب للعوده الى
المنصه لها بعد خطير بسبب الاخبار الزائفه
وقد لج
ا بحثا عن حمايه من اساليب ماسك في معامله
الموظفين
مكاتب تويتر في لندن في هذه البنايه هنا
شهدت اغلاقات مؤقته هي الاخرى بعد استلام
ماسك للشركه وهو الذي اتخذ عده اجراءات
زادت من التكهنات بان منصه تويتر
اما من الناحيه الاقتصاديه او من ناحيه
الوظيفه الاخلاقيه والمهنيه
عبد الحق العربي
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع في سياقها لكن بعد
قليل
ايران تتجه لتصعيد النووي لانهاء العالمي
عن الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
مستشفى المواساه بالخبر اول مستشفى في
القطاع الخاص يقدم خدمه استبدال مفصل
الركبه باستخدام الروبوت الجراحي من خلال
الاستفاده من خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي رحله
علاج اقصر واسهل المواساه خبره تنبض
بالثقه كل ما
تسمعه تقرا
قد لا يكون حقيقه يجب التسليم بها
فمهما بلغت اهميه الخبر
تاكيده او نفيوه يعتمد فقط على المصدر
كواليس وسائل الاعلام العربيه والعالميه
في التفاعل مع الاخبار على كل من الصوت
سنحاول رب خيوط القصه ونطارد الخبر حتى
المصدر من المصدر الجمعه السابعه والنصف
على شاشه العربيه
الاخبار لا تتوقف ابدا الناس تحصل عليها
من عده مصادر
من وسائل مختلفه طوال الوقت
[موسيقى]
وما هو اهمك
ويستدعي ان يصلي الضوء عليه لمناقشه
نضعه في عدسه واحده
لن يكبر الصوره لابعد الحدود
[موسيقى]
الثامنه على شاشه العربيه
عن اي استخدام المفرط للقوه في سوريا بعد
ان شنت انقره سلسله غارات جويه استضافت
مواقع للاكراد في سوريا والعراق وبعيده
تلويح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بشان
هجوم برين ضد المقاتلين الاكراد المبعوث
الخاص للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى
سوريا
اكد ان روسيا تبذل منذ اشهر كل ما بوسعها
لمنع اي عمليه بريه واسعه النطاق ضد سوريا
ونشد المسؤول الروسي ام قرى مواصله العمل
مع جميع اصحاب المصلحه لايجاد حل سلمي بما
في ذلك للقضيه
الموقف الروسي جاء من السنه عاصمه
كازاخستان حيث سيعقد اجتماع ثلاثي روسي
تركي ايراني بشان سوريا التلميح العسكريه
التركي في سوريا رفضته
اكدت معارضتها لاي عمل عسكري يز استقرار
الوضع في سوريا او ينتهك سياده العراق وفق
الخارجيه الامريكيه التي اعرضت ايضا عن
تعازيها لخساره مدنيين في كل من سوريا
وتركيا وتاثير مثل هذا الهجوم على هدفي
محاربه تنظيم داعش فنسى والمانيا اعرب متى
ايضا عن قلقهما اذا الغارات الجويه التي
شنتها تركيا وناشدتا انقره النفس
[موسيقى]
في تفاصيل الموضوع قالت تركيا في وقت سابق
ان فصائل كرديه قتلت اثنين فيها هجمات
صاروخيه من شمال سوريا وذلك في تصعيد عبر
الحدود عقب هجمات جويه جنتها تركيا في
مطلع الاسبوع وهجوم بقنبله في اسطنبول قبل
اسبوع وشددت القوات المسلحه التركيه انها
كانت ترد على الهجوم
الامر الذي يتحدث عنه صراحه وزير الدفاع
التركي خلوصي اكار الذي اكد ان عمليه
القذف الجوي التي تشنها بلده في شمال شرق
سوريا وشمال العراق هي الاكبر والاشمل
والاكثر فعاليه ضد المسلحين هناك
في منطقه اسطنبول سنجعلهم يدفعون ثمن كل
الجرائم التي ارتكبوها اليوم وما قبلها
وفقا لاخر المعلومات التي تلقيناها وفي
اعقاب غارتنا الجويه المدعومه باسلحه
ارضيه تم تحديده 184 مسلحها
وسيره الداخليه التركيه دعا الدول وخاصه
واشنطن الى وقت ما وصفها بدعم حزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
العمليات العسكريه التي وقعت مطلع الاسبوع
جاءت ردا على هجوم بقنبله في اسطنبول اودى
بحياه سته اشخاص وحملت تركيا حزب العمال
الكردستاني مسؤوليه الهجوم الذي نفى وقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه التي يقودها الاكراد
والتي تضم وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
تورطهم بالتفجيرات الهجمات التركيه دمرت
89 هدفا لحزب العمال الكردستاني ووحدات
حمايه الشعب التي تقول انقره انها جناح
لحزب العمال الكردستان
[موسيقى]
ومن اربيل لا ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
احمد الحمداني اهلا بك احمد يعني
استهدافات ايرانيه جديده لاقليم
كردستان فعليا هل من تفاصيل جديده حول
الاضرار هل من جرحه
طبعا بالفعل هي هجمات جديده على اقليم
كردستان وهذه المره الثالثه
استهدفت مناطق قرب اربيل
كوبري او المناطق الجنوبيه من اربيل
والمحاذيه لمناطق لمناطق محافظه كركوك هي
التي استهدفت بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
وكان مقرات
لاحزاب كرديه ايرانيه معارضه لايران
وطبعا حتى الان لم ترد اي همم حصيله لاي
خسائر لسبب بسيط هو ان هذه مقاراتيه فارغه
وقد اخلت المعارضه وعناصر المعارضه
الايرانيه مقرراتهم قبل القصف همم بفتره
حقيقه الان على ما لكن هي بالتاكيد همم
المؤكد الذي همم وصلنا هي خاليه حالها حال
كل المقرات
سودفت امس و وقبلها
وطبعا هي اا بوفق معلومات على ما يبدو
للمعارضه ان سعه الصفر بساعه الصفر لحرس
الثوري قبل الانطلاق وبالتالي اخرج جميع
المقرات ايران تستهدف المباني وتستهدف
البنا التحتيه للمعارضه معارضتها داخل
العراق
لم يكن هناك اي اصابات حتى الان او اي
قتلى حسب مصادرنا بالتالي فان همم ولكن
قبل يومين كان هناك قتيل واحد في الهجمات
العنيفه التي شنتها طهران على مواقع
المعارضه في اربيل والسليمانيه شرق اربيل
وشمالي اربيل
احمد همم كانت اربيل طالبت بدفاعات جويه
لحمايه اراضيها هل هناك من ردود افعال حول
هذا الطلب من الحكومه العراقيه في بغداد
طبعا الملفت بالموضوع او المفارقه ان حتى
بغداد ليس لديها دفاعات جويه بل ليس لديها
اي مضادات واي اي قوه للدفاعات الجويه
وكان وزير
هذا الموضوع ضمن برنامج الستيراد وصفقات
سلاح من الدول
المصنعه الا ان هناك من اعترض على هذا
الموضوع وهناك الجهاز سياسيه وقفت بالضد
من ان يكون هناك لدى العراق مضادات
ودفاعات جويه او رادارات وبالتالي العراق
بمجمله خالي وكان يعتمد على التحالف
الدولي وفق اتفاقيه استراتيجيه في في
موضوع الرصد الجوي
والامر معقد سياسيا على ما يبدو فبغداد لا
تملك فما بالكونستان الذي يطالب بغداد بان
يكون لديه دفاعات جويه الموضوع سياسي بحث
على ما يبدو وقرارات سياسيه في موضوع ان
يكون للعراق دفاعات جويه وراد تكشف
الهجمات والطائرات التي تخترق
اجواء العراقيه
وتدخل عمق العراقي بعشرات الك الامراض
وتستهدف في المواقع هنا وهناك شكرا جزيلا
لك من اربيل مراسل العربيه احمد الحمدانيه
وانضم الينا ايضا من بغداد مستشار رئيس
الوزراء العراقي حسين علاوي اهلا بك سيد
حسين يعني هناك تحركات سياسيه عراقيه بيان
من وزاره الخارجيه امس اليوم كان هناك
اجتماع للبرلمان اجتماع مغلق لم يخرج بشيء
واربيل تطالب بحمايه نفسها من خلال دفاعات
جويه هل هذه البيانات كافيه همم
لايقاف
الايرانيين عن استهداف الاراضي العراقيه
يعني مساء الخير عليكم مساء الخير على
المشاهدين الكرام واضح جدا خطاب اليوم
السيد رئيس وزراء الاستاذ محمد شيعه
السوداني في المؤتمر الصحفي قال ان انا لا
نريد ان نعطي مبرر لقصف الاراضي العراقيه
ولم نعطي اي اا موافقه على استهداف اي قوه
معارضه موجوده على الاراضي العراقيه لكن
بالمقابل هذه تخلصات التي هي لها امتدادات
طويله وعميقه على مدار 24 سنه حقيقي الان
الحكومه العراقيه برئاسه السيد رئيس وزراء
تضع خطه استراتيجيه سواء على المسار
السياسي او على مسار الفني وكذلك على مسار
البنيه التحتيه في عمليه مسك الحدود
وعمليه كذلك بالمقابل الحدود طبعا على
صعيد الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه وكذلك
الحدود العراقيه التركيه وكذلك بالمقابل
همم اجراءات القوات الامنيه همم ما بين
قياده العمليات المشتركه وقوات البشمركه
وما بين الحكومه الاتحاديه والحكومه
الاقليم وكذلك بالمقابل الاجراءات
السياسيه التي قد تكون بقرار سياسي همم
بالتشاور ما بين الحكومه عادي وحكومه
الاقليم وقاده القوه السياسيه العراقيه
وقاده القوه السياسيه داخل البرلمان وهذا
بالتالي ما سيعطي دعما الى قرارات السيد
رئيس الوزراء القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
للسيد محمد الشيخ خلال المرحله المقبله
وكذلك خلال الايام او اليومين المقبلين
مثل ما اشار السيد رئيس وزراء ان هنالك
اجتماع لمجلس الامن الوطني وسيتم طرح
الخطه الخاصه بعمليه اداره الحدود الدوليه
وعمليه التسويه همم السياسيه وكذلك
التسويه الفنيه لعمليه تواجد هذه الجيوب
للمعارضه الايرانيه او التركيه ان كانت
البكاكه او غيرها من الحساب الاخرى
الايرانيه المعارضه لايران على الشريط
الحدودي العراقي الايراني وهذا بالتالي ما
سيعطي همم دور كبير في عمليه مسك الحدود
وكذلك تواجد القوات الامنيه العراقيه مع
قوات البشمركه وكذلك بالمقابل مواجهه هذه
التحديات التي الان هي تحديات ما في
الامام الدوله العراقيه امام الحكومه
الجديده وامام كذلك بالمقابل القوه
السياسيه سيد حسين عن قرار لحل هذه
المناطل هل تضعون كحكومه عراقيه سيناريو
اجتياح بري ايراني وما سيناريوهات يعني
الموضوع من قبالكم ان حصل ذلك يعني الان
انت تعرف هناك توتر كبير ايضا واستهداف
تركي لي الشمال سوريا وهناك حديث عن
اجتياح تركي بري بري الا تتخوفون من ذلك
الحكومه العراقيه لديها الان القنوات
الدبلوماسيه مفتوحه ان كان من التمثيل
الدبلوماسي المتبادل او كذلك بالخطوط
المفتوحه ما بين وزراء الخارجيه وما بين
همم رؤساء الوزراء همم يعني رئاسه ايران
وكذلك رئاسه همم تركيا وكذلك الخطوط
المختلفه التي الان تمتلك كذلك الحكومه
العراقيه وكذلك بالمقابل الدعم الدولي
الموجود لدى العراق دبلوماسيه والذي يحث
الاطراف على همم يتوقف القصف وكذلك
بالمقابل ان تقوم الدوله العراقيه
باجراءاته الامنيه بالتعاون مع حكومه
تقليم كردستان وكذلك مع قوات البشمركه
وهذا بالتالي ما سيعطي فرصه الحكومه
العراقيه الجديده الان برئاسه السيد محمد
الشيعه السوداني لم يمضي عليها الا اسابيع
قليله هي لديها همم اوراق داخليه وخارجيه
تعمل على عليها من خلال المنهاج الوزاري
قام به السيد رئيس الوزراء في زيارته الى
الاردن المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه اشاره
مهمه جدا ان العراق تريد ان اا يذهب
بسياسه المحاور وانما يشجع همم العلاقات
الاقليميه والامن الاقليمي وكذلك يريد ان
يحافظ على مواطنه يحافظ على السياده
الوطنيه ويحافظ كذلك على الوضع الاقتصادي
الذي هو جوهر البرنامج التنموي لرئيس
الوزراء الاستاذ محمد الشاعر السوداني
شكرا جزيلا لك من بغداد مستشار رئيس
الوزراء العراقيه حسين علاوي
[موسيقى]
سوريا مختبر دولي للطائرات المسيره هكذا
وصفتها منظمه باكس الهولنديه لبناء السلام
قائله ان كل من الولايات المتحده وروسيا
وايران واسرائيل وتركيا فضلا عن قوات
النظام استخدمت 39 نوعا مختلفا من
المسيارات خلال النساء المستمر منذ العام
2011 وفقه وفوق بيوت السوريين ورؤسهم
اختبرت وطورت هذه الدول انواع الجديده من
المسيارات ودرست كيف يمكن لاستخدامها ان
يحسنا من التكتكات والاستراتيجيات
العسكريه في شمال سوريا تعول القوات
التركيه بشكل كبير على الطائرات المسيره
التي لعبت دورا في عمليتها العسكريه التي
شنتها منذ العام 2016 وتمكنت من خلالها من
السيطره على مناطق حدوديه كذلك اثبتت
الحرب انها افضل مختبر للطائرات من دون
طيار الروسيه وقد سمحت لموسكو ان تقيما
مسيرات حلفائها وان تختبره مسيرات مقاتله
واسلحتها وفقد تقرير الذي اشار الى دور
مهم لعبته المسيرات الروسيه في تغيير مسار
الحرب لصالح قوات النظام السوري
اذا زودت ميليشاتها في سوريا بمسيرات
استخداماتها ضد السوريين لصالح النظام
[موسيقى]
بشره ايران انتاج اليورانيوم
افادت وسائل الاعلام
النوويه
ضد النظام الايراني
احتجاج
يتعظم المد الثوري ضد النظام الايراني
الضغط الدولي الرافض لقمع المتظاهرين
ليزداد الخناق يوما بعد يوم فيما يبحث
النظام عن مخرج او كل مفر من ازماته
الداخليه الخارقه تلك
هنا تطل ورقه التصعيد النووي املا في صرف
او تحويل الانذار عما يدور داخليا تصعيد
يقابله الغرب برؤيه مواكبه لمجريات
التضارات الشعبيه تلك المانيا تتفق مع
امريكا بشان التركيز على ملف حقوق الانسان
بدلا من الملف النووي لكن طهران ومع
ارتفاع حده الغضب الداخليه ترفع مستوى
تخصيب اليورانيوم في منشاه فورد بنسبه 60%
كما تدشن سلسلتين من اجهزه الطرد المركزي
وهو اذا التصعيد النووي لكن ليس ذلك فحسب
بل ورقه الاخرى تلقي بها ايران صناعه
لاحداث في موازات ما يحدث من تظاهرات لا
تهدى
الاعتقالات حيث اعتقل النظام 400 اجنبيا
دون الكشف عن جنسياتهم متهما اياهم
بالضلوع في الاحتجاجات التي اشعلها مقتل
مهس اميلي دون تقديم ادله عن ذلك الاتهام
اوراق متعدده ترمي بها طهران وبكل ثقلها
مع التعمق ازماتها الداخليه واتساع دائره
التظاهرات المناهضه للنظام
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
مكاسب روسيا في اوكرانيا تتراجع
[موسيقى]
مدينه غيرت مسار الحرب العالميه الثانيه
الحروف
مونت اكتشافه وحتى يومنا هذا
نعتمد على نفقه ومشتقاته في سبل الحياه
توليد الطاقه قطاع النقل والمواصلات
الوقود واكثر من 300000 منتج اخر ليلعب
دورا مهما في الاقتصاد العالمي
لكن في ظل التطورات التي يشهدها العالم
والبحث المستمر عن مصادر متجدده للطاقه
كيف سيكون المشهد
تعرف على كل التطورات واخر المستجدات
المؤثره في هذا انقطاع الحيوي من صناع
القرار وخبراء العالم مستقبل الطاقه مع
ناصر الطيبي الخميس السادسه والنصف على
شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
الروس جحيما تقول صحيفه التلغراف سلاح
الجو الملكي البريطاني ارسل صواريخ
دريمستون وهي احدث نسخه من الصواريخ
الموجهه بالليزر ويمكنه الوصول الى مصر
بعيده القوات الاكرانيه قامت بتعديل
الشاحنات لتكون بمثابه من الصاج متحركه
لاطلاق صواريخ
لتدمير الدبابات الروسيه والمركبات الاخرى
من مسافه بعيده عاده يتم اطلاق الصواريخ
من الجو ولكن هذا النوع من الصواريخ الى
جانب اسلحه مماثله مضاده للدبابات ارسلها
حلفاء غربيون اخرون لاوكرانيا لعبت دورا
المحوريه في اعاقه التقدم العسكري دي
موسكو في الاشهر الاخيره اذا صواريخ خبرين
ستون يكلف كل منها حوالي
175,000 جنيه استرليني وتصيب الهدف من
خلاله تتبع الليزر الذي تطلقه القوات او
الطائرات او المركبات او تحديد هدفها
الخاص من خلال قائمه مبرمجه مسبقا من خلال
استخدام رادار الموجات المليمتريه عاليه
التردد يسمح هذا النظام للسلاح بمسح ساحه
المعركه تحديد الهدف الانسب مع استبعاد
المركبات المدنيه او المعدات العسكريه
الاقل الاهميه يمكن استخدام بريمسون في
المناطق السكنيه بدقه كبيره مما يحد من
احتماليه حدوث اضرار جانبيه بين سكان
المدنيين
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا حول هذا الموضوع من لندن
روبرت فوكس الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه
والامنيه اهلا بك سيد روبرت معنا في نشره
التاسعه يعني هذه الصواريخ عاليه الدقه
كيف يمكن ان تقلب عسكريه الدفه لصالح
اوكرانيا وعلى اي صعود بالتحديد
ابيس اسعار
جربت واستخدمت
في العديد من الحملات من قبل الطائرات
القوه الجويه الملكيه اولها الطاره
افغانستان
واستخدمه في داعش في سوريا وعلى حدود
العراق وكذلك في ليبيا
شايف ده كثير اي تي
88% من كان نسبه دقه هي موجوده منذ فتره
وتم تطويرها هل هي القوه الجويه الملكيه
ولكن حالها حال الاسلحه الاخرى التي صنع
البريطانيون
والتي يمكن تركيبها على طائرات فقد
استخدمت بشكل فعال جدا حتى في المعارك
البريه والهدف منها هي باربي الاهداف
المتحركه الروسيه المدرعه
ايضا سيد روبرت يعني روسيا بمقابل هذه
الصواريخ التي زودتم فيها كمملكه متحده
اوكرانيا تمتلك جيل جديد من الصواريخ
المتقدمه منها كنجال او الخنجر وغيرها من
الصواريخ كيف ستكون يعني فعاله بمعنى هل
فقد بعمليات فعليتها فقط على الاليات على
المدرعات ام على الدبابات
الروسيه همم
اطلاقها او استخدامها كما ذكرت ضد الاهداف
العسكريه
هذه الاسلحه همم الاسلحه البريطانيه
وارسالها الى اوكرانيا
زي زي
البرايمنس
الوزراء البريطاني ناقشه دفاع جوي وهذه
مساله حيويه جدا وهنا
يجب ان يعمل
او ان نحن نعرف الخلفاء ولكن بريطانيا
وفرنسا وامريكا والمانيا
والمانيا بدات تبرز فيها الصوره فيها الان
وفي الحقيقه هي تطور دفاعات الاهداف
المدنيه التي همم
حققت روسيا النجاح الاكبر خلال اسابيع 5
الماضيه اي شيء من الاسلحه التقليديه الى
الصواريخ المضاده الجديده وهندوره كان جال
هذه مضاده لها وكذلك مضاد المسيارات
الايراني فالكثير من الاسلحه ستصل الى
اوكرانيا
الاسلحه وهذا الصاروخ فعال فيها اكثر من
غيره وانت تتابع المعارك الحاصله في
اوكرانيا منذ شهور
يا
ايوبد
اكثر
الساخنتين مناطق التاليه ساخنه زفروشيه
كما نعرف هو في المناطق المحاديه
محطات النوويه الكبرى وبخمود
حيث هنالك الكثيره من النشاطات التي تقوم
بها القوات الروسيه خاصه
راس الرمح للقوات الروسيه هو في شبه
الجزيره
همم
المنطقه الهامه جدا
شبه جزيره كابنو لانها ليست فقط تحمي
خيرسون
وكل ما هو على غيرها وديسا وكذلك
تجعل من من استهدافي القرمه خاصه غربي
هناك
تجعلها منطقه ساخنه جدا وجذاب ولكن انواع
القوات التي سيستخدمونها هناك وانواع
الاسلحه
بلا مشاكل
يتكتمون عليها ولكنهم سوف يتم التوفيق
لتصبح صواريخها تطلق من العارضه وحتى بعض
الاسكندنافيين وفروهم سترون ايضا بعد
صواريخ البحريه
يتم ااا تعديلها للمعاركه البريه
والصواريخ البريه يتم تعديلها للحرب
البحريه فما شاهدناه
فيما خصه
للبر وكذلك ايضا كل هذه السنه منها في
المستقبل القريب جدا
روبرت فوكس الباحث في الشؤون العسكريه
والامنيه شكرا جزيلا لك
بورصه مكاسب روسيا في اوكرانيا تتراجع رغم
الاستراتيجيه الجديده تقوم صحيفه واشنطن
بوست الامريكيه التي اعتبرت ان هدف الكريم
من المبكر المتمثل بالاستيلاء على كافه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كانت طموحا جدا وسرعان
ما تغيرت المعادله لانها لم تتوقع ان
يستمر الصراع طويلا وما اعاقت تقدم روسي
هو عدم استعداد موسكو للقتال لفترات طويله
البيانات الصادره عن معهد دراسه الحرب
اظهرت انه بعد التقدم الروسي في الاسابيع
الاولى من الحرب لم تكسب روسيا اكثر من
1,000 ميل مربع في اسبوع منذ ابريل
استعاده اوكرانيا منطقه خيرسون بعد انسحاب
موسكو اكبر انتصار لكاف في الحرب حتى الان
وثالث ضربه لروسيا بعد انسحاب بقواتها من
الشمال في ابريل ثم من حركات في سبتمبر
بعد الفشل في الاستله على كاف كان الكرام
يملك ميدانيا وحدات سيئه التجهيزه واسطهم
في بدايه العديد من موارده وبعد ان فقدت
روسيا موادها في اوكرانيا وصلت الى مرحله
باتت غير قادره فيها على تحقيق اي مكاسب
كبيره وفق ما جاء في تقرير واشنطن بوست
بورصه مكاسب روسيا بعد ان ارتفعت تراجعت
قبل الحرب سيطره موسكو على نحو 17 الف ميل
مربع من اراضي اوكرانيا ومن ضمنها شبه
جزيره القرم التي ضمها الكريم من خلال
العام 2014 والمناطق التي يسيطر عليها
الانفصاليون في دونات ولكز الا انه هو
بحلول نهايه الاسبوع الرابع من الحرب
سيطره روسيا على نحو 51 الف ميل المربع اي
22% من اوكرانيا وما حصل بعد السابع عشر
من نوفمبر هو ان روسيا بات توسيطر على نحو
40 الف من المربع فيما يمثل نحو 17 بالمئه
من البلاد وهي اقل نسبه تسيطر عليها اوسكو
منذ ابريل
[موسيقى]
بعد اصابه العديد من طلاب المدارس خلال
الفتره القليله الماضيه حضر وزير الصحه
والسكان المصري من سرعه انتشار الفايروس
المخلويه التنفسي وزير الصحه قال لانه
طفلا واحدا مصابا بالفايروس قد يتسبب في
عدوى للمجموعه بالكامل في المدرسه سواء عن
طريق الرذاذ او التلامس مطالبا اولياء
الامور بعدم ارسال اي طفل مصاب للمدرسه
لان نسبه انتشار الفايروس مرتفعه الفيروس
المخلويه التنفسي هو مجموعه من الفيروسات
المخاطيه التي من الممكن ان تتسبب في بعض
الحالات مثل التهابات شديده في الجهاز
التنفسي
وتتسلل الى الجهاز التنفسي عند الاطفال
والاشخاص البالغين وفقا لوزاره الصحه ليس
هناك مضاد حيوي معالج لهذا الفايروس ولا
لقاح مضاد للاصابه به وهذا يرجع للتطور
السريع لسطح الفايروس ولكن يمكن الوقايه
منه من خلال اتباع بعض الاجراءات
الاحترازيه التي سل في غسل اليدين وتهويه
الاماكن المغلقه والتوقف عن تقبيل الاطفال
[موسيقى]
الاخضر يهزم التانجو في مباراه تاريخيه في
افتتاح المجموعه الثالثه بهدفين مقابل
واحد
بسبب عمليات الانتحال تويتر تؤجل مجددا
اطلاقا خدمه توثيق الحسابات بالعلامات
الزرقاء
الولايات المتحده وروسيا دونان القصفه
التركي شمال سوريا والعراق
وتطالبان انقره بالضبط
لصالح اوكرانيا